ein taugen nichts ist doch im
Sprachgebrauch ganz genau jemand der auf
Kosten der anderen lebt der sich selber
nicht einbringt der sich unsozial
verhält das ist ein tauge nichts den man
zu nichts brauchen kann die anderen
trinre Z an wen denken sie da das sind
beispielsweise bürgergeldempfänger die
arbeitsfähig wären und eine zumutbare
Arbeit ablehnen das ist nicht der
bürgergeldempfänger der wirklich
bedürftig ist der krank ist und so
weiter sondern das ist einer der auf
Kosten der anderen lebt obwohl er anders
könnte und ein taugen nichts ist auch
jemand der in einer Regierung sitzt
keinen Schulabschluss hat den Leuten
käise erzählt und selber noch nie
gearbeitet hat und am Ende Dinge an die
Wand fährt auch das ist an wen denken
Sie jetzt konkret ja brauch ich keine
Namen nennen vielleicht fen fallen ihnen
selber einig sagen sie doch das andere
habe ich gesagt be Bürgergeld na weil
ich dann angezeigt werd vielleicht von
niemand